did you like the local people while you
were there when you're in a small sort
of New England town and it's pretty
rural of a cooky they're very nice the
town I was in is a fantastic place to
live if you're like a mid 50s well-to-do
white couple with a beautiful golden
retriever that was the general it was
like Elizabeth Warren cosplay good and
then yeah I would I would go to the
movies a lot there was just nothing to
do we the cast was all really spread
apart and so I would go to the movies I
saw some weird weird stuff at the movies
you saw weird things at the movies yeah
not weird movies but weird stuff Oh like
people yeah because you go to like one
of those tiny theaters in a rural area
characters come out of the woodwork oh
I'll say yeah and all of the movie
theaters have those reclining seats that
go like pretty much flat back so you're
seeing people be weird like as if they
were in their beds at home which yes it
even stranger essentially lying with
strangers in a small room watching a
movie in a rural area enjoying cinema
yeah yes I saw a woman and her husband
they sat next to me and this woman had
this big bucket of popcorn and she like
spilled out half of it and then from her
big purse she took this I don't know if
it was Parmesan cheese but it looked
like a craft Parmesan cheese like the
big the big one and she did she shook
the whole thing into this now half
bucket of popcorn he put like a half
pound of grated cheese all the cheese
she had to empty out half the popcorn to
make room for the cheese and then she
reached into her purse and pulled out a
spoon that she brought from home
an ADA ate the popcorn with a spoon the
whole time and then would feed her
husband and he didn't even have to look
at her he like knew this was their
routine
he just had open his mouth and she would
[Applause]
I know those guys I know them that's my
dad's family
[Laughter]